when you pay for your morning coffee do
you reach for this or this
is still what most people prefer but
digital wallets like Apple pay Google
pay and PayPal have become more popular
over the last several years especially
for online payments and that's making
the banks whose cards are in your
physical wallet worried as Chase CEO
Jamie Diamond said about the growth of
new Financial technology in 2021
absolutely we should be scared about
that and apple is one of big bank's
biggest threats
here's how the tech company is
encroaching on traditional finances
territory and how banks are gearing up
to fight back
we've created
an entirely new payment process
and we call it
Apple pay when Apple pay was introduced
in 2014 it wasn't the first digital
wallet but it had a big advantage over
its competitors the iPhone and now Apple
pay is activated on 78 of iPhones in the
US
if you want to use an iPhone in store
it's very difficult to use a different
wallet like when you tap and pay at the
register then Apple pay it was also the
only digital wallet that Banks agreed to
pay a fee for every transaction here's
why
Banks make money on debit and credit
card purchases from interchange fees
which Merchants pay to the bank that
issued your card when you shop with it
those fees are usually one to three
percent of your purchase when you shop
with a credit card so if you buy that
coffee for five dollars and your credit
card has a roughly two percent
interchange fee the bank gets about 10
cents
but if you use Apple pay the bank has to
pay three quarters of a cent to Apple
rather than pocketing 10 cents on the
five dollar transaction the bank would
instead keep just over nine cents on one
small transaction that doesn't seem like
much but it adds up Apple took in an
estimated 782 million dollars from Apple
pay last year initially it was like well
you know better to be on board with this
and have our cards used on Apple pay
than be cut out completely because if
you know we don't play ball what could
happen could Apple develop some other
mechanism that cuts out cards fees Apple
collects from Apple pay only make up
about one percent of the company's
revenue from services
that includes things like the App Store
Apple music and iCloud but that number
is growing it's estimated that the
amount Apple pay collected nearly
doubled between 2020 and 2022 but it's
not just money that banks are losing to
Apple it's name recognition it's not
good enough for the banks to be the
underlying card that's used on one of
these third-party wallets their concern
is that once you lose that entire
experience it's just a slippery slope
from there where eventually you'll have
a tech company that is actually the
lender and they don't need you behind
the scenes
Apple pay isn't the end of Apple's
Ambitions with consumer payments but we
want to take the Apple pay experience
even further in 2019 it partnered with
Goldman Sachs to create the Apple card
and in March it began rolling out its
own buy now pay later program Apple's
subsidiary Apple financing LLC will be
the lender effectively taking over the
role that many banks and other financial
institutions would usually take and now
that consumers are getting used to
engaging with Apple for their payments
it doesn't seem so far-fetched right
that consumers would be interested in
engaging with apple on a deposit account
or some other type of payment mechanism
an apple spokeswoman declined to comment
but banks have also introduced their own
new tech in the last few years many have
rolled out tapped to pay cards with
similar technology to your phone that
makes it just as easy to check out in
store now they're preparing to compete
with apple in online payments too with a
digital wallet of their own called pays
this is a very clear-cut example where
the banks have kind of had enough and
are trying to figure out a very specific
way to compete against Apple pay and
PayPal the new wallet will be operated
by a company owned by these seven major
Banks pays will allow customers to
access eligible debit and credit cards
by entering an email potentially
speeding up the online checkout process
still the banks will only succeed if
people actually use it and Merchants
agree to accept it after all this isn't
the first time banks have tried to
launch their own digital wallets Chase
shut down its app Chase pay in 2021 in
part because of limitations with the
iPhone according to people familiar with
the matter
talk about consumer behavior and
shifting that behavior right now people
are very used to paying with Apple pay
with PayPal there have been tons of
wallets that have launched in different
forums over the years and they failed
they fail to gain traction as Banks try
to compete with their own digital wallet
tech companies are trying to create apps
for more than just payments what is
certain is that the battle between the
banks and tech companies will continue
period until
a winner emerges everybody is convinced
that there will eventually be a small
number of Super apps that control
consumer payments and financial services
so now they're basically duking it out
to figure out who it's going to be
[Music]